Alright Charles, you were about to say, how we could do this.
>> I think the answer is, simply, that we basically need to flip the, here's
my thinking. We need to flip zero and
one, which suggests that either our weight or
our threshold needs to be negative. And since we, we The threshold is in above,
it's going to end up being our weight being negative. So, let's say, if we have a
zero, we want to turn that into something above
the threshold and if it's a one, we
want it to be below the threshold. So,
why don't we make the weight negative one.
>> Okay.
>> And that, that turn a zero into a zero
and it will turn a one into a minus one. Alright.
>> And so, then the threshold just has to be zero.
>> So that would mean that anything,
I see, so anything that's negative will be
greater than, zero or negative would be greater than
or equal to the threshold. And anything on the other
side of that. would be under the threshold. So
we get this kind of dividing line at one, so
were taking advantage of the fact the equation had
a greater than or equal to in it. So, yeah,
right, that ought to be a Not. So ,we've got
And, Or, and Not are all expressible, as perceptron units.
So and, or, and not are all expressible as perceptron units.
>> Hey that's great because if we have AND,
OR, and NOT, then we can represent any Boolean function.
>> Well, do we know that? We know that
if we combine them together, we combine these perceptron units
together Can we, can we express any perceptron, oh sorry,
any boolean function that we want using a single perception?
>> So, what do we normally do in this case?
So ,what's the most evil function we can think of?
>> Yes indeed, we'll when we're woking on, on decision trees The
thing that was so evil was the XOR, the called parity more generally.
>> Right.
>> So, alright. I mean, may, maybe if we can do
that, we can do anything. So, let's, let's give it a shot.